-It's a beautiful show,
"Big Mouth."
-Thank you!
-You know what I hear a lo
is people my age who have
children who are in their teens,
they watch it together.
And the parents say to me --
A lot of them know
that I know you.
They say, "I can't believe
I'm watching it with my kids
that I'm allowing them
to watch it,
but we have so much fun
watching it,"
because it's so honest
about things like puberty
that otherwise,
parents have no idea
how to talk to their kids about.
-Yeah.
I think what we're trying to d
is create a show that give
people a vocabulary and platform
to talk about things
or spark some conversation
between parents and kids.
And who doesn't want to si
next to their child
and watch animated
children masturbate?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But it --
-It's the dream.
-It is the dream
for everybody involved.
I got excited.
-You got nominated for an Emmy
for Best Animated Show
this year.
Congratulations.
-Thank you very much.
-Very exciting.
-Thank you.
-And also really exciting news
Netflix picked it up
for three more seasons,
which is a very --
I mean, it's so nice
in this business for any of us
to know that you have
that much road ahead of you.
-Yes. We're incredibly fortunate
to be able to do it.
And we -- The first couple
seasons of the show
were really kind of
a nostalgic look back
at me and Andrew Goldberg's life
and our writers and everybod
else involved in the show.
And then Season 3, we star
to talk a little bit more
about what it's like
to be a kid now.
My character Nick is --
becomes obsessed with his phone.
And we got Chelsea Peretti
to be his phone,
who's named Cellsea.
And Ali Wong guest-stars
as a pansexual girl.
-Whoo!
-Yes. Yes.
Give it up for pansexual girls
as well.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we're keeping things ver
current.
We've got Wanda Sykes as
the ghost of Harriet Tubman.
-Great.
-So, you know --
-Very current. Very hip.
-Very hip.
-You're on tour with your show
your "Middle-Aged Boy"
stand-up tour.
And you found some super-fan
of "Big Mouth."
So, this is a man who had
a tattoo of the hormone monste
who asked you to sign it.
-Yes. Yes. He asked me --
Yes. He had a hormone monste
big tattoo on his thigh,
and then I --
and then he asked me to sign it.
-And then he got
your signature tattooed.
-Yes. Yes.
-So that's a lot --
I mean, that's a lot of --
I feel like that puts a burden
on you to keep the work good
because that guy
is now a fan forever.
-Yes. But it also gives
a burden on me
to, like, sign his leg
correctly.
-Yeah.
-Like, that, I was --
Because I was in a rush,
and I signed it,
and I was like, "Alright, man.
And that's it. Like,
that's on his body forever
-Yeah. Do you -- I notice that
he does have a lot of tattoos.
Does that make it better
than if it was the first tattoo?
-It makes it a lot less special.
-Yeah.
But I think if it was the --
if the only thing he wante
was your signature,
then you might have a seriou
stalker on your hands.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. No, i
was, like, it was nice to know
that Charlie Day from
"Always Sunny in Philadelphia"
was there.
-Was also there.
-He might go down first.
-You've been on tour.
-Yeah.
-You just were in Toronto.
-Yes.
-Do you drive?
-Yeah. I've driven up throug
to Toronto and Montreal
to do the show.
And I was driving up
and listening to the radio
And NPR was on.
And then about 20 miles
before the border with Canad
it, like, ominously
became the CBC.
-Yeah.
-Like, the Canadian
version of NPR.
And I wasn't really listening.
And then all of a sudden,
I hear something.
I was like, "What is that?
And it was like,
"And then the bear
broke into
the marijuana dispensary
and began to Dumpster-dive
and have some fun.
It was against the rules.
However, we should
always remember
that we are on the bears' land."
[ Laughter ]
It was like
the most Canadian [bleep]
I'd ever heard in my life.
-We do have to remember, though.
We always forget
we're on the bears' land.
-Of course.